rob kardashian is getting flirty online
I need someone to make me luck
the reality star quote tweeted a topless
selfie of singer naughty natasha
publicly writing oh hi
while many fans told him not to go there
she actually retweeted the comment and
on Tuesday tweeted a video of Rob's
daughter dream captioning it princess
god bless her there was magic there
everyone felt it Rob's personal life has
been pretty quiet since his tumultuous
relationship with dreams mom blac Chyna
what do you think I'm doing but he
started resurfacing in rare appearances
on Keeping Up with the Kardashians it's
really just it takes either one person
to man up obviously it's gonna have to
be me but at the same time I'm not gonna
argue with the female we had a good talk
the other night so we'll see and last
month at drag con China gave us an
update on how the two are making
co-parenting that work you and Rob have
been so good about each other and it's
been really nice to see that is it does
it feel good to be in that place yeah I
feel like you know like heaven cuz I
have two babies by the way he and Jamie
I just felt like having like a good
relationship with the other parent at
co-parents and is like a healthy type of
thing and there's something that a lot
of people needs to like practice what
does the next chapter for blac chyna
look like just being more like open and
like more verbal and just like
connecting like with the people and just
trying to figure out like what's the
next and
that like as far as I've been a mom a
friend a business owner and just like
overall